this past weekend siege's north american
mini major came to a close
now not only did the long-suffering dark
zero
finally earn themselves some
much-deserved silverware
but following months of doom and gloom
around the need to save
siege ubisoft unveiled one of the most
era defining updates their game has
ever seen not since the invitational
has the future of siege looked this
bright
from match replays to an overhaul of the
sound engine
to a splinter cell crossover ubi is
introducing features that fans have
spent months
if not years clamoring for now there's a
lot of changes to get through
some of which are pretty radical but
suffice it to say
siege will never be the same
alright guys so we've been streaming
over at twitch.tv slash the score
esports for a little while now and one
of the things that we've been
streaming is our talk show clouded where
the don't at me team breaks down the
biggest stories in esports and streaming
and talks mad [ __ ] while doing it so
make sure you go and follow the channel
so that you catch clouded every week
when it goes live wednesday at 1pm
eastern time
okay back to rainbow six let's kick
things off with the esports stuff so
despite
barely making it into the tournament
dark zero came out of
nowhere and cobbled together an
absolutely staggering run
after toppling the defending world
champions space station gaming in the
quarterfinals
they proceeded to topple team bolo mid
in both the semis
and grand finals team solomid
what did i say anyway it was lovely to
behold because despite being this
grassroots locally sourced startup who'd
been on the up-and-up for like
two years dark zero had never actually
won anything
and then in the one tournament in which
they weren't actually expected to do
anything they went ham good trigger
discipline
he'll need to drop and he does so he
sees the blitz drawing all of the fire
away defuser goes down successfully the
odds of him winning getting even harder
he's flashed
and dark zero turns the lights out on
tsm
as dz are your north american
major champions but the even bigger news
came in between the second
and third map of the grand finals where
much to the team's dismay
ubisoft decided to shove in the reveal
panel for siege's newest operation
shadow legacy hailed as being one of the
most significant quality of life updates
the game has ever
seen shadow legacy is quite frankly the
breath of fresh air that siege not only
needed but deserved the headliner of
course was the game's newest operator
the difference is that for the first
time ever ubisoft decided to round out
siege's roster with a brooding badass
from an
already existing franchise now his call
sign is zero
but if you're a fan of splinter cell
he's sam fisher
you should know better than write me off
next they drew the curtains back on
something that the siege community has
been waiting for since thermite was
knee-high to an exothermic charge
a chalet rework things we wanted to
improve was
uh the objective making it a bit more
fair and attack
and on defense making it a bit more
interesting
the way you attack the map now is
completely different than before
long has chalet held the distinction of
being
arguably the most dog [ __ ] map in ranks
it wasn't so much that it was actually
the worst as it was that it somehow made
it through
years of scathing criticism unscathed
from tower and favela to skyscraper
fortress
and both iterations of hereford base
nearly every one of the
truly awful maps in the ranked pool has
at some point been
crushed by the community's incessant and
altogether
warranted whining but not chalet
at least until now honestly it makes me
kind of emotional to see chalet
finally get clapped it feels like the
end of an era
what are we going to complain about now
oh
right out back huddy outmate
that said ooby did finally bring map
bands into ranked now i may not be able
to decide exactly what i want to play
which to be clear is crucial to
preserving the competitive integrity of
ranked
but at least i can have some say in the
matter since for a while there it felt
as if cueing into ranked was just
online gambling we would like to give
the agency to the players
to to influence what maps they are
playing or what maps they don't want to
play
this will reduce the frustration of the
player who doesn't want to play this
certain map and
and also can even lead to sometimes uh
toxic behaviors of rage quitting next is
not only one of the most exciting
changes but
perhaps the most unexpected a literal
overhaul
of the weapon site system first of all
we're introducing
two new sites a new red dot and a new
holographic site
we are also bringing in two new scopes
now
if you're a non-acog user like me who
slaps the holographic
on everything simply because you hate it
marginally less than the red dot and the
reflex
you're gonna be one happy camper not
only have they added
four new sites but they've made them
super customizable
like seriously i'm still trying to
figure out how to convert my sensitivity
with those new sites and scopes we're
also bringing in
more customization for the players you
will be able to customize the
sensitivity of
each of those zoom levels we are
introducing the
accessibility tab in the option menus so
this will be the last app that you see
when you open this you will have plenty
of choice for colors of your reticles
now for a ton of people this is a
massive deal not only have ubisoft made
weapon sites more personalized but
they've added a whole bunch of
accessibility options
color blind mode probably being the most
significant there's still a ton of
balancing to be done around this of
course but that's the great thing about
virtually all of the changes that
ubisoft is implementing
they're taking loads of feedback so
seriously get on the test server see
what you like
and don't like and make yourself heard
next we've got
pooled reinforcements this one is pretty
straightforward
each defender now has access to all 10
reinforcements
meaning that when your spawn peaking
jaeger who refused to put down any
utility runs off and dies three seconds
into the round
he isn't taking two of those ever so
crucial hard walls with him
alright the next change is probably my
favorite
papa ooby is bestowing upon eight often
under utilized attackers a
hard breaching secondary gadget so in
the
past few years we saw that the
attacker's composition
is uh quite rigid and bringing a hard
breacher is a must
and we would like to ease it a little
bit and with the secondary
gadget the attackers don't need to bring
a dedicated hard reacher and maybe it
can lead to some more exotic peaks now
while you're still
going to need to bring an actual hard
breacher
it's going to be less important if they
get spawn peaked in the opening seconds
of the round
honestly this one might be the most game
changing but
i for one think it's great and i'm
really excited to see how it pans out
but the way that they're adding the drop
down reinforcements on the ceiling
and then um introducing more hard breach
that they can
change by the way you know like if they
want to give that gadget to someone else
they can do that they can
take it away i think that that's going
to make heart breach more dynamic more
interesting
in the in the future and less rigid ah
yes the contextual pain right now we
have
only european but with new pen system
you just have to
pin the gadget and there was a icon
tells you which
gadget is there so when you pin
enemy gadget you will be able to also
reveal operator's identity on top of the
screen
of all the changes this is the only one
that the community has
actually gotten up in arms about which
again is totally okay
because ubisoft is being very receptive
to criticism
but as of right now it definitely looks
a little overpowered
next we've got one of the most slept on
changes but one that us csgo stands have
been clamoring for for what feels like
an eternity fixing
siege's god forsaken sound engine
imagine every map in the whole of
counter-strike being as
nonsensically echoey as nuke
that's what it's like to play siege oh
you heard footsteps above you
then your enemy is almost certainly
eight inches to your right
needless to say the technical aspects as
to why it was so bad
are way above my head and i have no idea
what they did to fix it
the good news is that by all accounts
they did located
i heard the nerd i heard the sophia i
heard them i heard everything
the sound is so good ooby also
finally got around to dishing out the
long expected nerf to the
single greatest operator ever to round
out the rainbow roster
thatchicans gps satellites unmanned
drones
[ __ ] laser sights after years of
watching as thatcher dominated
literally every level of play ooby
finally brought the undisputed goat down
a peg
instead of destroying the vast majority
of round defining gadgets
his emps will simply disable them making
the operator
a shitload less oppressive as of now
in the game thatcher's emp grenade can
have multiple effects on the defender's
gadget some of them are destroyed right
away
and some of them are disabled for a
certain amount of time and then they
come back to life
we would like to unify this and from
season 3
all the defender involved gadgets will
be disabled
instead of destroyed last but not least
we've got match replays now this might
not sound all that enticing to use
silvers out there but this might
actually be the single
most important addition when it comes to
preserving the health of the esports
scene
you will start from the perspective of
the spectator
so you will be able to see the map and
the players from the top
view but i think even more interesting
it will be that you will have access to
each player view
regardless if it was your teammate or if
it was your enemy
you will be able to see all the points
of view which is pretty exciting
imagine being a coach analyst or
competitor
and not having access to a go tv
equivalent
for literally every single person who's
made it their mission to play siege at
even a remotely high level
this is life changing there's other
stuff too removal of vote to kick a
redesign of the actual bomb
and changes both to mmr rollback and the
minimum gain loss
but suffice to say shadow legacy is one
of the biggest patches
siege has ever seen and while all of the
kinks
bugs and balancing acts have yet to be
ironed out completely the overwhelming
consensus
is that it is awesome and that it will
reinvent siege
like never before this update to siege
looks like it's going to completely
change
most things and
we're definitely definitely in the
middle of an era shift the crazy thing
is that ubisoft put
all of this together the mini majors and
like the most
uprooting update their game has ever
seen
amidst a global pandemic now there are a
lot of
silver threes on twitter who in addition
to boasting 18
followers and a weeby ass profile pic
live to spout on about how ubisoft don't
care about their game
the thing is after this patch even those
idiots can't deny what a load of
garbage that is personally i think that
shadow legacy is the best thing to
happen to siege
in a long time maybe ever
i'm not gonna lie i got a little bit
burned out after shifting tides
and found myself playing even more cs go
than usual
but if there's anything that's gonna get
me back into siege
it's this in fact i don't think i've
ever been as excited to play
rainbow six siege as i am right now
given what we're working on
and what's going to happen during the
next year oh
this one might be more difficult to
sleep with before the reveal because
these are these are much much bigger
changes coming to the game we want to
make sure that in 5 years in 10 years in
15 years when people look at siege
they don't see just something that was
super successful a few years back but
has
kind of grown dusty we want to just we
just want to
keep on evolving for context dmitry was
a valor and gamer for what the first two
seasons
or two not even i played i played like
really seriously in the closed beta
and then that was kind of it honestly
i will say playing the only good thing
about playing valerian
is it [ __ ] it sends you back into the
arms of counter-strike man and you
just you oh baby oh
baby you're like this is how it was
supposed to feel man oh you forget you
take that [ __ ] for granted you take
actual movement for granted yeah opting
in balance sucks dude i think the game
would be better without the op that's my
like hot take is that if they actually
took the the op out of valoren and it
was just rifles only
the game would be so much better what's
in the canisters
[ __ ] laser signs all right golem
forever